-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
I hope you had
a great two weeks.
We had a good two weeks, too
Let's get to the news.
[ Laughter ]
Sir Richard Branson
yesterday became
the first billionaire
to travel to space.
Okay, did he, though?
I watched that launch and
would not call that space.
Space is dark
and has stars in it.
Look at this graph.
That's not a rocket.
It's just a plane
that got cocky.
[ Laughter ]
Just because you touched net
doesn't mean you can say
you dunked.
Branson's like one
of those guys who say,
"Yeah, I've been to Texas,
and then, you find out
he changed planes once
at Dallas-Fort Worth.
[ Laughter ]
Call me when you're
on the Moon, Richard.
Surprised he didn't
call me yesterday.
He probably got cell service
up there.
[ Laughter ]
80 kilometers?
That's not even worth
mentioning at a party.
[ Laughter ]
During the weekend's
CPAC Convention in Dallas,
the crowd cheered
when a speaker noted
that the country had faile
to reach its vaccination goal.
Well, technically, it was a mi
of cheering and coughing.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Senator Mitt Romney
reportedly sold
his San Diego home
for more than $23 million.
The home features a pool
and Jacuzzi, exercise room
and two milk cellars.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Johnny Carson ]
You hear that, Ed?
Two.
[ Laughter ]
Disgraced comedian Bill Cosb
was released from prison
last month
after the Pennsylvania
state Supreme Court
overturned his
sexual assault conviction.
And I know this probably goe
without saying,
but don't sleep on Bill Cosby.
[ Laughter ]
Jeff Bezos officially
stepped down last week
as the CEO of Amazon.
There's a card
being passed around.
Just make sure you punch out
before signing it.
The fast food chain Popeye
recently began offering
a so-called I Don't Know mea
for indecisive customers,
while Subway released
an I Don't Know meal
because, legally,
they can't call it tuna.
[ Laughter ]
Pope Francis made his firs
public appearance yesterda
since undergoing surgery
a week ago.
And looks like
the procedure went well.
[ Laughter ]
[ Italian accent ]
No, it was not that.
He's not Italian.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I think I --
I mean, I think, you know,
you spend enough time
at the Vatican,
you start talking like that,
no matter where you're from.
[ Italian accent ]
No, I went in for-a
kidney stones.
[ Laughter ]
A customer at a bar
in New Hampshire
recently left an anonymous
$16,000 tip on a $37 tab.
Although, according to the
panicked voice mails left
on the bar's phone,
his name is Chad
and, no, he did not.
According to a new report,
every New York City classroo
will reportedly have
two air purifiers in September
to lower the risk of exposur
to the coronavirus.
To save money, they're going
to replace teachers.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
fish are able
to develop addictions to drugs
like crystal meth.
On the plus side,
it's now actually safe
to go back in the water.
[ Laughter ]
"Uh, actually,
sharks aren't fish."
[Bleep] [Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
Ugh! Pbbt!
Back to that.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
according to a recent study,
people in positions of power
are more likely
to blame or punish others
for their mistakes.
Well, I mean,
that doesn't sound right.
Scollins.
Scollins, again.
Three days in a row
from Scollins.
I think those were
all fair hits.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue.